[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host dr john
dolone ramsey personality best-selling
author of the book redefining anxiety is
uh my co-host today and we're going to
answer your questions about your life
and your money if you've not heard the
dr john baloney show yet on podcast it
is our fastest growing podcast at the
moment and
you should chime in he talks all about
mental health and boundaries and your
crazy relatives and your crazy self and
whatever's going on out there that we
need to deal with with relationships and
so forth and it is a
an informative fun and sometimes really
poignant show so be sure and tune in to
the doctor sometimes
sometimes rarely no it is okay it is i
was listening to it this morning i
listened to the one that the podcast
that dropped this week and it's very
good it's very good and it's even going
back and reviewing some of your first
shows because it's the anniversary
edition that just dropped uh your first
year we've been doing this for a year
you've been doing it for a year
that's a weird twist of fate man that's
a weird world
good grief
wherever you happen to be ladies and
gentlemen it could all be very different
a year from now yeah well and um
yeah or 30 years or yeah you never know
sure in your case 111 but it's good it
could always be different it could
always be different oh well we can we
can help you with that if you want to
shorten it
111 i don't know
open phones at
825.5225 get him out of this before he
gets in trouble brian's in quincy
illinois hey brian what's up
hey how are you doing today guys better
than i deserve how can we help
well my wife and i live in a small town
about a thousand people and we're having
a hard time finding a house to kind of
grow
um
you know a bigger house for us so we're
thinking about adding on currently our
house does not have a garage so part of
the addition would be a two-stall garage
and then adding a mud room with laundry
room in half bath and then extending our
living room as part of it
we don't know if that's a wise decision
however housing
there's no houses for sale in our small
town but if they are they're either way
too small or way out of our budget
just looking for a little advice
okay
well there's nothing to compare it to
obviously you don't have a lot of
options uh if you're going to stay in
that little town
how close are you how close are you to
another uh town that you could just move
over one
well we really like the school system
that's the problem we we it's a small
town community the town i work in is 20
minutes away and it's about five times
as big of a school system we just love
the small town community where we're at
okay that makes sense
yeah it makes sense uh but not if you're
going to spend 200 000 that you're going
to lose
no no the addition's around 50 to 55
000. you have the cash
uh no we would have to basically we were
kind of looking at it as if we bought a
house we would do a construction loan
and then roll that into a permanent
mortgage yeah uh but everything would be
what's your household income
our household income is just about 72.
okay and what's your current first
mortgage amount
uh 70.
okay well i mean you got 120 000 bucks
in this house when you're done and it's
a difficult market to sell a house in
so that's that's what you're that's what
you're signing up for you're signed up
for a long term play
okay
and um
and probably not a lot of escape hatches
for this
so uh be careful about rationalizing it
or justifying it or whatever and moving
on past common sense
so i mean what you've described is not
completely out of control
um it just sounds very um
i i i just tell you any time in my life
this here's what's bothering me okay you
can go ahead and do it brian if you want
to do it that's fine okay but here's
what's bothering me and i will put the
principle out there for you for me for
everybody else
anytime i start
saying to myself there's only one way to
solve this problem
that is a lot that makes any sense at
all
that means i have not thought about this
enough and i'm getting ready to make a
stupid butt error and that's the way
you've described this whole situation
and that's what's bothering me about it
okay because you you've clipped the
edges off of this thing six different
ways to where there's no way to come to
any possible other conclusion other than
the one you have come to
and um
i always like to have a whole bunch of
options uh or just back up and throw a
grenade in the middle of it and just to
make me rethink what if because every
time i
i i clipped the edges off of it i said
well the school system and well the
other house is in the town and oh then
you came to this and then there's this
and there's that and you know we gotta
have something bigger and you just keep
you know you keep working your way down
to where there's only one possible way
to solve this issue because of the
limitations you put on the decision
you set yourself up with a
decision-making framework for making a
mistake that's right and
i i don't like this for a couple
different reasons dave i don't like it
because he's adding
garage he's going to add square footage
to this home but it's not going to be
stuff that's generally counted right
it's going to be a half bath and then a
garage space and some storage space and
it'll be nice features but it's not like
he's had in a bedroom or a master
bathroom things that are easily roid
right well you say you had a living room
built in there but that's that's but an
extension but you've got that and then i
always want to push back on this
this is the only school yeah it's
smaller it's this and usually that comes
from a lot of internet research or
that's the way i did it or some
mythology me and my wife had to deal
with the fact that our kids school
experience is different than ours and i
keep leaning back towards there's the
right way to do it which happens to be
the way i experienced it
and then have to breathe and exhale and
realize there's a whole bunch of
different ways to do school and i'd much
rather see him look closer to work and
think about the life he could get back
fifty thousand dollars what could that
buy him in that community that he could
sell again
i love the way you framed it we just
usually reverse engineer you know what i
really want is a cool garage we need a
bigger living room
and i'm gonna make these facts fit this
narrative and then i'm going to have to
go borrow money and do something silly
yeah all right and i don't like it
i don't like how you came to the
conclusion but the conclusion is not
completely off the table so again if you
want to go ahead and do it i'm not going
to yell at you and call you stupid or
something like that that's not what i'm
saying i'm just saying that anytime
somebody calls me up and goes there's
only one way that always bothers me
because every time i do that i screw it
up
i would love i think it'd be worth a
trip for you and your wife to go down
and meet with the principal of a local
school by where you work and just feel
what that'd be like maybe you've already
done that but i i think that'd be worth
doing it oh interesting idea all right
coming up next is jonathan in salt lake
city utah hey jonathan how are you great
dave appreciate the influence you've had
on me and my adult children it's made a
huge difference honored listen uh
listen uh i my wife and i have been debt
free since 1994.
we have six rental properties and the
salt lake real estate market uh has gone
up like a rocket and we've already
benefited
uh
we our children each of our three adult
children still have home loans
we're thinking of selling one of our six
rental properties it was an exchange
property
and uh giving each of them a hundred
thousand dollars to reduce the principal
balance on their loan so that they'll
get them paid off sooner so what we're
trying to do
is accelerate them getting out of debt i
love it i would do that now what you do
need to do is you need to talk to your
tax advisor because you're going to take
a unified estate tax credit because you
cannot gift somebody a hundred thousand
dollars even your own kid without
getting into gift tax unless you use the
unified estate tax credit so talk to
your estate planner your tax advisor on
how to do it but the concept
paying off your kids houses you're
breaking you're changing the family tree
i love it i i would have a caveat on
there that they're not going to go back
in debt you don't go buy a new cadillac
show it up help your house right but
we're going to go that direction
[Music]
me
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess with health care costs
rising learn how christian healthcare
ministries can help you make the most
out of your budget visit
chministries.org
budget don't worry
it's worth it
[Music]
open phones this hour i'm dave ramsey
your host you jump in we'll talk about
your life and your money
dr john deloney rmg personality is my
co-host today hey homeschool parents we
know that preparing your teen for the
real world can feel like a big job
especially when it comes to teaching
them
money topics
but you can do it and our homeschool
curriculum can help foundations in
personal finance has helped over 5
million students learn the money lessons
that they need
now and down the road best part is it
has all the lesson plans the video
content activities already created
giving you some needed time back in your
day if you're a homeschool parent text
home school to 33789 to learn more about
changing
personal finance curriculum for middle
and high schoolers home school to 33
7 8 9. neville is with us in charlotte
hi neville how are you
hi dave very happy to be on your show
how are you
better than i deserve what's up
so i'm 23 years old i just got a new job
of making 87 000 a year before taxes
and i'm not really sure when i'm going
to be married or have a house within the
next possibly three to five years but i
do want to save up for them uh do you
feel as though i should continue
with me not knowing when i'm gonna have
those actions do you think i should save
up for them
still in like a cd or a bank account or
should i invest that money into
a mutual fund as i'm doing with the rest
of my money great good job what are you
doing for a living
uh i am a project manager with a company
that ships stuff to your house that has
a little smiley face on it
[Laughter]
oh that one okay 87 000 awesome at 23
years old that's impressive sir awesome
very cool
very cool yeah thank you well first
thing is we have to be debt-free and
have an emergency fund have you done
that
uh yes i'm technically past uh baby step
three i do have the about three to six
months of expenses my expenses changed
because i just moved back in with my
parents as i got this job but i do have
uh what was six months of my previous
expenses okay all right yeah i'd start
putting go ahead to baby step four and
put 15 of your income aside for
retirement beyond that you're saving and
investing for these other things you're
talking about
and um you know the closer to five years
that you're going to have that money
parked the more likely i would be to
move towards mutual funds
uh you know when mutual funds are
volatile and they go up and down because
the stock market goes up and down but if
you leave it alone five years you have a
very high probability of making money on
it percentage-wise the number of in the
five-year periods that have lost money
is almost none
uh but uh twice as many uh two year
periods so we've lost money so you got
about a 50 50 chance at two years of
losing money uh or making money but if
you're parked in a savings account
you're making one percent
so
um me if i'm 23 i'm gonna play that uh
because you don't have any set plan
right now for when you're gonna buy you
don't have any set plan for marriage
those kinds of things so i'm gonna go
ahead and play that long play because
it's probably gonna be pretty close to
five years before you have to actually
cash that in and use it is that agreed
yes that makes a lot of sense
are you dating somebody right now
uh yes i am um but the way my job kind
of works i travel a lot so i don't
really have a home location and thus i
don't really know whether or not i'm
going to be moving in with this person
or marrying them really anytime soon
that sounds more like a them like a
relationship issue than a job issue but
we can say that for another phone call
how about that
[Laughter]
good deal yeah i want to know if he was
just thinking i hope to
maybe uh some spouse will fall out of
this guy or we're getting there we're
getting closer there yeah that's a good
good clarification that's incredible 23
years old way down the road there that's
fantastic well done
michaela is with us in new york city hi
michaela how are you
good how are you dave better than i
deserve what's up
so
yeah me and my husband we got married
last year in march 2020 and our first
goal was to pay off my husband's student
debt and credit card
which was uh 28 000 and that was uh
together we live here in long island new
york and i have some students that
oversee
so i'm originally from sweden
uh and i have a 29 5 000 student loan
but my interest rate is
0.05 i don't care which means that
right now i only pay 12 a year and i'm
not taking any further loans so
so you want to keep it like it's a pet
because it doesn't eat much
now the dilemma is that we want to start
a family in the near future and we live
in a one-bedroom apartment
and um yeah we are just debating if we
should no debate pay it off pay it off
pay it off don't start a family while
you're still chained to something
overseas
yeah let's get that paid off possibly if
you have a baby before the student loan
uh is gone and before you have the money
to move into a different property
uh then just move to a two bedroom
yeah we have eighteen thousand saved up
right now oh good how much does a
student loan
twenty nine five uh twenty nine oh good
we only got ten thousand left so pay 18
on the student loan today
pay it off are you there
it is it is but here's what's going to
be real emotional when you start your
family with
chained to nothing yeah here's the thing
the question you're really asking us is
what is the shortest distance between
where i am today
and being stable financially and wealthy
financially and the shortest distance is
don't screw around with a student loan
and keep it around like it's a freaking
pet you have to kill that thing
and get rid of it and that will give you
more stability and a shorter distance to
wealth and stability financial peace for
you and your family than keeping it
around and it's in the closet growing
and munching over there
and just chomping like some kind of
monster in the closet like some kind of
cartoon or something and no no no no no
clean up your life
when you have no payments
you feel different physically
when you have no payments your
relationships are changed when you have
no payments your mind is clearer to make
better decisions
you're a better mom
no question about it and uh it's not to
say if you're a bad mom if you have debt
no don't give me those stupid tweets
but the uh but the point is i mean when
you when your mind is clear and free of
the anxiety and the stress associated
with debt it opens you up to be a better
husband better wife better employee
better better version of you you sleep
better you eat better you just walk
through life better yeah right and
that's what we want for you and yes
you're gonna have another year of saving
for a house and that's okay
you got plenty of time
tom is in omaha nebraska hey tom how are
you
good dave how are you today better than
i deserve what's up
well i just um
i've been listening to you a lot of
years and i thought hey it's time to
give you a call i about a year ago my
mom passed away and left
some land and some money with us i have
about a hundred thousand dollars cash i
parked and
i just thought hey just leave it sit for
a while until everything gets kind of
calmed down and
decide what to do just curious if i
should pay my house off or debt freaks
at the house we do have six months
emergency fund set up so i didn't know
if i should pay the house off sure
and uh move on up sixty four didn't know
if that mattered right um all right why
wouldn't you
well here's the reason i called you i
had a guy not one of yours but not one
of your trained people which i am gonna
look into next week but he wanted to
sell me an annuity hundred thousand
dollar annuity and i i said no i'm not
gonna do it i've been listening dave
long enough i'm gonna i'm gonna run run
like the wind and uh get away from that
and so then i got thinking well should i
invest it
and to uh
tom tommy number one you knew what i was
gonna say for you called right
yeah you know what i did i've been
listening to you yeah
so this is this name we're just chasing
our tape we're just chasing our tail
here but that the um so uh here let
reverse engineer it for a second you're
64. i'm six i'm turning 61 this week
okay about the same age all right you're
sitting there in a paid for house
would you go borrow on it to invest the
money
absolutely not same dadgum thing dude
imagine being 64 and heading into
retirement with no payments on your
house and just being completely free
imagine doing that by 5 pm today what a
gift
that your mom will have left you there
that's incredible this is the ramsey
show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed perfect fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsay personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt free stage mike
and carrie are with us hey guys how are
you better than we deserve dave how
about yourself just the same sir where
do you guys live uh lakeside arizona and
what's that in there uh it's near
flagstaff oh yeah beautiful area cool
welcome to nashville thank you and here
to do a debt-free scream how much did
you pay off we paid off 288
495
nice how long did this take uh six years
and three months way to go and your
range of income during that six years so
we started at 21 450 and ended at 121
860 000. that's a little jump okay what
do you guys do for a living now
uh i am a management analyst for the
state of arizona and i'm the office
manager for a construction company ah
very cool what kind of debt was this 288
i'm guessing with six years might have
been your house personal loans house
uh credit cards cars and mostly student
loans but we sold the house to help pay
off some of that debt oh the house is
gone
where are you living
we have a different house that we stay
in now we sold that one though to help
catapult us okay is in the one you're in
now paid for no no okay all right so
okay i wanna make sure i get my story
straight so you got a bunch of student
loan debt yes about 133 000 wow what was
that from what was the degrees
mine is in business management and
mine's in health information systems
about half each or
okay all right good for you guys okay so
how long you guys have been married 20
years today oh
happy anniversary
very nice so
what in the world happened six years ago
put you on this journey so the end of
2014 november he'd gotten laid off from
his job and i was about a week away from
having our fourth son
and
working part-time we were already living
paycheck to paycheck and that really
just that killed everything we were
doing yeah
so that's scary as crap it is um i had
heard you on the radio driving our kids
to school in the morning and it had
always struck a chord with me
um
so we had talked about it and decided
that was better than what we were
currently doing
and when we got our tax return that
january we ordered several of your books
and as soon as i started reading them i
was hooked
he worked on finding employment again
full-time i went from part-time at my
company to full-time employment we both
took a second job
doing our rideshare in our community wow
nights and weekends wow then a few years
into the journey i actually had the
opportunity to teach your college
curriculum for our local community
college nice so at one point we were
working five jobs wow with four boys
and just kind of chipped away at it took
us six years obviously but we did it
well it sounds like the income has been
on a journey it has yeah all over the
place
wow i'm not afraid of hard work either
no way willing to put it in it's kind of
cool were they was the community college
paying you to teach dave's class yes
that's incredible yeah that's a win on
top of a woman it was awesome i loved
teaching it that's fantastic well thank
you for doing that and thank them for
paying you that's exactly right life is
good that's a good that's like everybody
everybody's winning in this story i like
it
very cool man that's a long journey it
is how do you how do you stick with it
for a six-year grind
so hard work and dedication and if you
fall off the wagon so to speak uh just
hop back on and just get get back on
track yeah not every day was perfect on
the journey obviously it's that long so
you just have to forgive yourself
make those mistakes and move forward
gary when you were telling us the story
about when he lost his job when you were
pregnant
you grabbed his hand real tight though
that's still sitting right there on your
chest
it's a good and a bad moment it got us
to where we are now i wouldn't change it
now but in the moment we were terrified
yeah that's still with you that'll
probably be with you for for a while
what about you man was that scary coming
home having to
let your wife know your pregnant wife
know you just lost your job yeah i
almost didn't want to tell her but yeah
right didn't want to at all yeah right
it was a week before we had him so it
was and it was right before thanksgiving
so it was just
it was a tough time wow kudos to you man
for
dusting yourself up and uh getting back
out there and saying that i'm gonna do
two and three and four jobs we're gonna
make this thing happen good for you man
oh thank you it's incredible we also
cash flowed several things during that
time um medical we have four boys so a
lot of medical a lot of medical
vehicle repairs and he's going for
another degree right now so we've been
cash flowing all of that excellent
finished baby step three so we're on to
four five and six excellent incredible
good for you guys it's awesome thank you
proud of you guys great job rock stars
thank you sir absolute heroes man this
is that's amazing very very very cool
good good stuff well we got a copy of
the legacy journey for you that's the
next chapter in your story for sure to
move on to baby steps millionaires now
that's right that's where we're headed
and uh and of course total money
makeovers so you can give that away and
get someone started on their journey
because you'll bump into somebody you
know you will right there's no way
around it they're everywhere they need
this need to know this information so
good stuff all right mike and kerry from
the flagstaff arizona area 288
000
paid off six years in three months
making 21
to 121 over that six years up to five
jobs at one point count it down let's
hear a debt free scream
three two
one
we're debt-free
[Applause]
[Music]
when you don't have any payments and you
make 121 you can put some money back and
turn everything around they just turned
a corner they don't even know it oh man
and she looks at him like she likes him
this is so good and vice versa yeah yeah
well that yeah you go through six years
of of hell together to come out on the
other side
and man i don't know that light shines a
little bit brighter on that person
sitting next to you right now this is uh
we can do anything we've been battling
together yeah we could do anything
absolutely that's incredible guys
powerful stuff christopher is with us in
richmond virginia hi christopher welcome
to the ramsay show hey guys how are you
doing better than i deserve how can i
help
okay so i'm just giving you a rundown of
basically who i am in my background so
i'm a 22 year old senior at virginia
tech actually so fingers crossed
hopefully this year i'll be done um i'm
going to fourteen thousand dollars in
loans after i'm done with everything
which is pretty good considering i don't
have to pay anything yet for school and
financial aid has just covered
everything
um basically right now i have twenty
four thousand dollars saved up and seven
hundred dollars in stocks and stuff like
that right now my major is in sports
media is in communication so i'm just
going to stick with it as i'm a senior
right now so there's really no point in
switching yet
before i run out of time what's your
question christopher
um basically my thing is i don't love my
major anymore and i'm not really
passionate about the sports side of
media anymore and i've been looking more
into stocks and basically just like
looking at stocks in real estate so my
thing is what can i do to set myself up
for success but now that i'm basically
lost in life i've never felt so lost at
one point in life so at this point i
just don't know where to turn or what to
do with my money or anything
okay as far as the money part goes you
graduate and you're going to have a
degree in
sports management which gives you some
business background and some business
classes under your belt and you can walk
into the financial world and use that
you can walk into the real estate world
and use that that's right you do not
have to go back for a master's in one of
those areas i wouldn't no absolutely
wouldn't spend the money you've got the
money in the bank to pay off your
student loan as soon as you get
gainfully employed i would do that
and the rest is your emergency fund and
then let's start investing and uh
working on your career getting your
income up and getting moving i think you
can do it and there's this illusion that
everyone who graduates with their major
you think that everyone around you
walking through their senior year has it
all together
what i want to tell you is everybody
else is scared too
the world's chaotic it feels even more
chaotic and when you're looking at the
job boards and that this and that i'm
not i'm not keen on this
don't stress yourself out don't strike
yourself out you've gotten this far
you're gonna be good to go and like dave
said that degree you have can send you
in any number of directions in the
business world you know you could we do
not have a single sports team at ramsey
not one and you could walk in here
interview and you know we would look at
you for a position absolutely based on
the way you carry yourself based on what
you could bring to the table in the
particular area you're trying to deal in
and you know you should have some
academic underpinning to be able to add
value in some businesses somewhere and
it has nothing to do with sports i want
you to find one or two
men in your life that are ahead of you
five years ahead of you ten years ahead
of you and just sit down and say hey i'm
about to graduate in a year i started to
freak out a little bit and i'm nervous
and um uncomfortable and let them speak
some wisdom and truth into you yeah
if they're the right kind of man they'll
say i was too
and i am still sometimes
because all of us are sometimes
this is the ramsay shop
[Music]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality host
of the dr john deloney show
is my co-host today
he's also the author of the bestseller
redefining anxiety it's one of our quick
reads it's an 80 page quick read on
redefining give you a whole new look on
anxiety and uh
most everyone struggles with it at some
level some debilitating uh some passing
and driving by
some ongoing but hey it's it's a word we
are all well acquainted with
so check it out
sometimes it helps it to uh
it makes it behave to give it a proper
name it just demystifies the whole thing
there you go yeah to properly label
things and
not uh not falsely identify yourself
with them so yeah check it out
redefining anxiety it'll help you you
can also join john on his show the dr
john delaney show our one of our fastest
growing podcasts here ask john
ramseysolutions.com send in an email
kelly will get back with you make you
part of that show and we'd love to have
you brandon is with us brandon is in
cool springs
colorado springs i'm sorry colorado hey
brandon how are you
i'm doing great mr ramsey dr john thank
you so much for taking my call sure
what's up
yeah uh just calling to see if i can
kind of do a little bit of a suzie orman
thing with you uh i have uh
dave ramsey thing yeah
yeah sort of uh does it fit into the
ramsey plan here we're looking to
purchase a home
uh in the mountains it's gonna be a
vacation home kind of uh near one of my
ski resorts i love going to cool
you got the money um so we're looking
i'm so sorry do you have the cash
uh
oh to purchase it cash yes
uh no but we do have a down payment yeah
i wouldn't do it
a second a second home is a toy
and you pay cash for toys if you want to
be wealthy
i've got a lake house i'm heading to
this afternoon when i get off the air
and i paid cash for it a long long time
ago and then i rebuilt another one on
the same property and paid cash for that
and i absolutely love it
i would have 23 years later hated the
stinking thing uh however if i had been
paying payments on it as much as it sits
empty
and it's just you're just not ready to
buy a second home you don't need to be
doing vacation homes when you don't have
the money to pay for them what do you
tell somebody dave that has this
imaginary spreadsheet with all of the
airbnb
guests they're going to have to float it
all and all the it becomes this funny
math where we talked about this earlier
here's the thing
using debt to do stuff like this
only works when it works
and nothing ever works
in life the way you think it's going to
never know never the best laid plans of
mice and men you just you just know you
know you can project this this yellow
brick road experience
and then you'll run into the wicked
witch every time and and the flying
monkeys
and uh those little those little oompa
loompa guys look like poodles with the
curved swords
remember them yeah
you're going to run into all these
things along the way the yellow brick
road is fraught with danger including
stupid
straw men that have no brain
they're out there everywhere and you
know this is what you run into so this
stuff only works if it works and nothing
ever goes exactly as planned
and the beautiful thing is when you're
on a bunch of rental property and
you don't have any payments and there's
a pandemic or something
and some of your tenants can't pay
um because they lost their jobs it's not
their fault
uh you can grant mercy um but when you
have payments
you're the one needing mercy that's
right
and but but but those tenants will pay
off that rental property for you you
heard that crap see that's what that's
that yellow brick road thing you left
out the flying monkey yep you know you
left out the pandemic you left out the
big bad wolf i'm going to mix up a bunch
of different stories here together in
this metaphor but you know but you see
what i'm saying and that that's the
problem is um
that that uh
it happens every time too it does go
every time life is predictable life is
happening it's gonna happen i've never
thought of a vacation home i love the
way it's a toy yeah it's a toy it's fun
especially if you want to buy a
four-wheeler a motorcycle a boat it's a
toy yep you know but if you got to put
payments on it that just means you're
too broke to have it that's right yeah
and because this you know i added up
when i was broke
because i'm a water skier i love the
lake i love the i love the mountains too
like he does i'd love to have i don't
have a ski house but i wouldn't mind
having one they're wonderful and um
but i added up one time when i had
payments on a boat when i first started
doing this stuff about 30 years ago um
that i well it was longer actually
longer than that ago but i added up with
the payments i was making on the boat
the insurance on the boat
what it cost me per minute to ski
[Laughter]
i averaged out that i was going to ski
this many times a year and i would ski
10 minutes this run i'd ski five minutes
that run and skate 15 minutes that run
and i added it up and uh a buddy of mine
started telling me about how he needed a
better bass boat and so i added up per
pound what the bass was costing him
and it was something like 14 000 a pound
you know or something i mean it was like
okay so hey that brings that's a good
ques a good question then how do you
decide so if this guy's going to try to
buy a ski house that he likes and he
goes and visits it seven times a year
which would be a lot of ski trips you
cannot get you cannot financially
justify it so it only time is justified
is when it's you've got the cash in hand
it's not you're not it's not financially
justified and it's not about investment
it's about it it's about not harming my
life there you go because it does not
make sense it's a lifestyle choice okay
you know you've been to my lake house
okay so if you say
i mean that one makes sense that's a
pretty cool house it's a beautiful home
and it's a great investment it's gone up
in value that that's fine but you know
the number of hours we spend there the
number of weekends we spend there the
amount of time we spend on the water
you know could we not rent an airbnb on
the lake
and come out millions of dollars ahead
absolutely we couldn't
but we've got the money
and it doesn't
hurt our financial situation because
we're not paying payments on it
and so but when you you you know you've
got to look at because it truly is a toy
you know you cannot justify i love that
idea you can't financially justify these
things at all none of them uh they don't
make sense um
and so you know with what you spend on a
vacation home how many times can you
know you can rent a
just outside colorado springs i've done
it you can rent the uh
15 000 square foot mansion
on the side of a mountain ski and ski
out for thirty thousand bucks a week
thirty thousand bucks a week right okay
and if you go four weeks a year okay
let's see that's 120 000 bucks right
that's right and so how long does it
take you to get to 5 million bucks
that's a lot of weeks you know you
cannot financially justify it right you
can't financially justify it but but if
you've if you've got a hundred million
dollars and you want to drop five
million dollars in that thing it's a toy
and you can afford it then it doesn't
matter that it doesn't financially work
it's a place that's yours it's your
families it's memory you know the
difference between a five thousand
dollar car and a twenty five thousand
dollar car you can't justify it
financially
but if you can afford it it's okay to
take that bit of a luxury hear you go
you know it's the same kind of a thing
because both of them will get you from
point a to point b so shut up stop your
whining right and both of them probably
got air conditioning so shut up and stop
your whining and both of them are
somewhat reliable so shut up and stop
your whining so the difference in the
five thousand twenty five thousand
dollar car is a want right
and and it's okay well i'm not against
once on this show but you have to pay
cash for them
uh and you it because the upgrades are
luxury there you go and so living like
no one else so later you can live and
give like no one else so put yourself in
that position is what i would do i love
that dave i love it
that's the direction to go and i want
you to get a vacation house i'm not i'm
not saying i'm doing something and
telling you you shouldn't
but i didn't the first property and
again you've been down there we had our
personalities retreat down there
but the first one i bought was 103 000.
it was one tiny little lot wow off to
the right-hand side of that property and
it was this little bitty brick house
from 1974 on it and we had a boat dock
all i care about was a boat dock and a
place to sleep that's all i cared about
and a place to put the boat and you know
have fun and ski the kids and tube the
kids and all that stuff and the kids
were tiny
and
you know now all these years later we
bought several properties adjacent uh
did some tear downs some rebuilds built
a nice
big home on there now
and uh and you know all the grandkids
saw seven of them and all the maybe 14
15 people the ramsey clan down there
this weekend you know for labor day
weekend right so but you we worked up to
that over 25 years
and we paid cash for it and at no point
was it a big percentage of our world
including so it was never a burden yeah
it was only fun right yeah and because
it just takes the fun out of it
and also i guess it gets you in the land
of stupid real quick oh yeah and then it
gets to the land of justification and
then all of a sudden yeah one glitch one
one flying monkey and the whole thing
comes down yeah if you gotta if you got
the down payment only hun just go rent
yeah just go rent it three times a year
and until you've got the money and when
you got the money buy it
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
dave here we just launched a brand new
listener survey we want to know what you
think about the show you'll be entered
to win a 100 amazon gift card no
purchase necessary take the survey at
ramseysolutions.com
survey or text survey to 33 789
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host thank
you for joining us open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five dr john delony
personality best-selling author and host
of the dr john deloney show one of our
fastest growing podcasts here in the
ramsey network
is my co-host today he talks about
relationships mental health anxiety
boundaries whatever we need to talk
about and we'll mix all of that in as we
answer your questions about your life
and your money again open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five matthew's in new york city hey
matthew how are you i'm great dave how
are you better than i deserve what's up
um so i'm in a little bit of a car
situation um currently i'm on step two
no me my wife are on step two um i have
13 000
left in credit card debt to pay off
um currently we just have one car i got
fleece three years ago pre dave ramsey
um
so that is up in february i'm five i'm
over the mileage and i'm gonna end up
owing five grand on it um i just
also on top of that i'm gonna need to
buy a second car we just had a baby and
we currently only have the one car so
we're gonna need that i'm gonna need to
buy another car
and you're gonna turn that one in in
february right
i have to turn that one into february so
we got about two cars
i have to buy two cars yes sir okay so
what do you make
uh household income is around 220 000.
that's good news
okay
well i i think what we have is we have
uh uh
a lot at the end of the tunnel and it's
a train
coming at us
it's february
between non-february we gotta buy three
cars
our two cars and we gotta pay and we got
a five grand
and we gotta somewhere and then after
some time after that we're gonna pay off
thirteen thousand dollars in credit card
debt but your prior what's your first
priority your first priority is be able
to turn this car in so you need five
grand treat that like it's a debt
that's debt number one in your debt
snowball
uh priority number two is you you
currently have one car we need to at
least replace the current one car
and so another five grand
for a five thousand dollar car
is number two and number three
i guess we can get the second car before
we pay off the credit card debt what do
you think
yeah that'd be great okay so that's
another five grand
so i need 15 grand to do the car flip
and i need 13 grand to pay off the
student loan or to pay off the
uh
credit cards i get a spit out here in a
minute so you need 28 000 you make 200
between now and february if you do all
of that by february you're debt-free and
have two paid for cars that are worth 5
000 bucks each does that make sense
yeah it makes perfect sense yeah i think
you can do all that you make a call you
make a god-awful amount of money it's
awesome i'm proud of you but you're
gonna you're not gonna do nothing else
don't talk to me about going out to eat
or going on vacation you have a car
crisis
and you still have credit card debt and
you make a quarter million dollars a
year which is just straight up stupid so
you've got to clean this up right okay
does that make sense
yeah it makes sense yeah so uh just to
so fi so i can find a car for so
basically find two used cars for five
grand yeah yeah what do you do for a
living man
uh i work for the sanitation department
in new york city so i would need i need
a car with all-wheel drive because when
it snows that's my main job is to plow
the streets
so
we i need to get i need to be able to
get to work get to where it's right um
so is there going to be any sort of let
me just say it this way you're going to
have to get over any sort of ego you got
about the salary you have and rolling
into work with a 5 000 car because your
co-workers are going to give you grief
appropriately so and you're going to
have to just smile and say i don't know
nobody nothing right
yeah you're going to have to go and by
the way i don't want you to drive a 5
000 car the rest of your life i'm just
trying to get you past february
after february you have zero debt right
yeah that's your debt and you make 200
000 plus a year right
yes and so once your emergency fund is
saved up i would save up and move up in
car
okay with cash
yeah
and uh so i'm asking you to drive a 5
000 car for less than a year
okay but if you'll drive like no one
else later you can drive like no one
else
that makes sense yeah i drove hoopties
after i went broke and people made fun
of me i had one the vinyl roof was torn
loose across the top when you drove it
it filled up there and looked like a
parachute going down the interstate and
i was so embarrassed
i was so embarrassed
it was so i would you know can you get
to work every day with worse is pulling
up in the church
and my face is red the whole time and
you know what i just said screw it i
don't care whether you can take your
hand and you just try to i try to paste
it on and it just slowly poof back down
in front of me that's it
no that's the headliner i'm talking
about the vinyl roof on top oh on the
outside like a tourist across the front
yeah build
mine fell down on the inside no this was
this was the opposite of aerodynamic
yeah
sharon is on the line in louisville
kentucky hi sharon how are you
hi dave i'm good thanks for having my
call sure well i have a beautiful
daughter he's a junior in college and
she wants to be a veterinarian
we have
helped to pay for her undergraduate and
she received scholarships that help to
pay for that great but the next level of
graduate school is going to have to be
out of state because we don't have an
in-state veterinarian school in kentucky
really and the state of kentucky
horse country does not have a vet school
wow
i'm flabbergasted we
we asked that question when we visited
the university of kentucky
and they said it was too expensive it
was
cheaper to have a relationship with
auburn
for in-state tuition for a certain
number of kentucky students
than to have a school
what about tennessee they got a big vet
school
tennessee does have some veterinary
schools yes but again out of state for
us and they don't have they don't have a
relationship with kentucky because it's
just across the line
that's correct does that hold for
graduate school because most graduate
schools set across the board tuition
that's not contingent on on residency
status usually that's an undergraduate
thing
have you checked the prices of the
tennessee vet schools
um
it has been a few years since since i
have looked it up i looked it up more
when she was in high school
check on that um check on that because i
know there's last i looked it's been a
couple years but there's a shortage
across the country on vets and there was
a
a groundswell of of a push
um to how can we increase the number of
grad students and when that happens
usually there's a collapsing of the
tuition of some sort or high scholarship
incentives where they waive state fees
and and all that kind of stuff so i
would definitely go sit down with those
schools and leverage that the best you
can sharon john has a phd in higher ed
so he's played in this sandbox a bunch
so that he's not he's not just making
this up he's not just making this up
university of tennessee knoxville's vet
school is huge and awesome by the way
and so is auburn's you mentioned auburn
they both are great vet schools both
have a great reputation but i would just
be shopping my tail end off and find the
best deal just like you did when you put
her through undergrads how you get her
to go through and just be careful don't
don't run up 400 000 bucks be a vet
this is a ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
if you're ready to get out there and
find a job you love then you need to
hear this
job hunting can be stressful and time
consuming but my friends at zip
recruiter have made the whole job search
way easier ziprecruiter is rated the
number one job site in the us by g2 and
it's free so how does it work
first go to ziprecruiter.com
ken
then create a free profile and let their
technology do the hard work by finding
and sending you jobs that are a great
fit and get this
zip recruiter pitches your profile to
companies whose jobs match your skills
and experience if someone from that
company likes your profile they can
personally invite you to apply for the
job so if you're ready for an easier job
search check out ziprecruiter sign up
for free right now at ziprecruiter.com
ken that's
ziprecruiter.com
ken sign up today absolutely free and
let zip recruiter work for you
[Music]
so
[Music]
guys we'd love to hear from you what you
think of the ramsey show and we're doing
a survey about the ramsey show
and we'd love to have you take the
survey if you'll do it for a few minutes
i will be in the drawing for a 100
amazon gift card
text the word survey to 33 789 take a
moment and tell us what you think about
what's going on around here we love to
hear that you uh love dr john deloney
and um if you have negative things to
say don't take the survey no
that's that's right senator kelly.daniel
only send kelly the hate mail text
because we're sensitive text survey to
33 789 or visit ramseysolutions.com
survey in all seriousness we'd love to
hear from you our question today comes
from blinds.com find out for yourself
why blinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings you
get free samples free shipping and with
the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more use the promo code
ramsey to get the best possible deal all
right today's question comes from
jennifer in kansas
my husband is 100 sure that the world
will end soon or martial law will take
effect and money will not hold any value
because of this he will not save he has
business and personal credit card debt
he has zero savings and spends his money
as fast as he makes it he's up to date
on his payments but has no interest in
paying them off so he can start saving i
am currently saving as much as possible
and will have the last of my debt paid
off later this year
i have life insurance in place for all
of us and a 401k he will also be able to
draw my pension at my old job if i
should pass before he does i feel like
i'm the only one preparing for our
future and honestly it's hurtful
i don't know how to get through to him
that even though the world may end in
our lifetime we should still be
responsible with our money and be
prepared
how can i get through to him
dave
how can she get through to him um
well i mean
the extreme way you've explained him
this is not somebody who's merely a
prepper this is not someone who is
merely
feels like that the culture is uh
deteriorating this guy is so sure
that he's so paranoid that that the
whole thing is going to crash down
that he according to you this according
to jennifer that he is doing nothing
responsible
uh he's just living his life today now
or
he's a complete liar
and this is his excuse for being a
freaking child right
um and doing whatever he wants to do
either way this guy is exercising
at a level of mental illness that is
pretty extreme right
this is a paranoia
situation or it's a depression that is
lapsed into i i literally can't think
through
to tomorrow so i'm just living for the
next five minutes the next 10 minutes
yeah and um i'll create this narrative
and i will find some websites that will
back up my narrative there's there's a
thousand of these conspiracies millions
of them websites and
you know all you gotta do is watch the
news and it makes them all come true
that's exactly right and uh but they're
not you know so um
let me just tell you that
the world has problems
and uh the world has always had problems
100 of the time and uh but the uh
percentage likelihood of martial law and
of you losing all of your personal
assets coming together in your lifetime
is so small that to believe that 100 to
the point that it affects your behavior
where you do nothing responsible for
your family is called paranoia that is a
mental illness level this is not merely
we have a disagreement about how life
works this is you are your husband is
mentally ill and so let me am i wrong no
and in fact here
dave um what i had a seizure in the
doctor on life when um
i had you and i've talked about this i
had mapped out in a very um beautiful
mind kind of way
where this data point led to this one
and this one and i wasn't well and i had
come to figure out that oh the housing
market was gonna re-collapse and they
were going to have to nationalize i had
created this whole world and so i was
going to cash out this and go do this
and i'll never forget sitting with the
cfo of a 200 million company i sat down
explained what i was about to do with my
retirement i was going to cash it out
because money's not gonna and i remember
him gently looking at me and saying i
don't really understand this please
don't do this and i left that meeting
and i thought he didn't see it he didn't
get it and i'm a guy that barely knows
how to work a spreadsheet right so
here's the thing
um when somebody is in this position the
data and facts don't help a lot
with somebody in this position needs to
go get help yeah i had to go sit down
with somebody and say i'm i'm seeing the
world different than everyone around me
who loves me and i need some help yeah
and you're right the world's got
problems it does
one of my close friends gave me a quote
that has stuck with me forever and he
said john i got a lot of plans
but i don't have a meteorite plan if a
meteorite hits us i will deal with that
on that day
and the idea that suddenly money is
going to hold no value and tanks are
going to roll on every street
if that happens i'll deal with that on
that day and until then i'm going to be
responsible and care for my wife who
feels like she's drowning over here by
herself and we're going to go from there
yeah
he's not going to give in to that
because it's futile right
it's just futile
yeah there there's yeah he he needs to
see he needs help he needs to see a
counselor yeah he needs help so jennifer
no amount of you sitting down trying to
explain stuff to him is going to how can
i get through to him you can't you
cannot you can't because his brain is
not functioning properly right
if somebody in his life that he is
somebody that he trusts that would sit
down with him and say hey let's go talk
to somebody great if you say hey i'm
going to go talk to someone i'd love you
to join me to be great
but he needs to get some help yeah
and by the way he he doesn't think he
needs help so that's probably gonna be
very difficult so but just to
the point is is that this is not he
isn't
you're not gonna solve this riddle
you don't have the tool set i did have a
friend that came and spoke truth to me
my wife spoke truth to me and i wasn't
this bad um but uh that was helpful it
was two people that i trusted and i said
i'm gonna go talk to somebody then yeah
well and i think you might get some
guidance from a a good counselor if you
were seeing one on how to deal with this
situation because here's what's
ultimately going to happen okay having
dealt with couples in your situation for
30 years
one of two things is going to occur
and there's really not much middle
ground there's not a third thing it's
one of two he is going to recognize this
get some help and gradually over time
get better and your lives are going to
get better and get more normalized and
you're going to be able to aim at a
future and build build some wealth and
get out of debt and start living
reasonably and you're going to start
taking some incremental not
instantaneous but some incremental steps
in that direction which will give you
hope
if that does not occur
100 of the time
at some point you are going to boil over
a switch is going to flip
and you're going to be done
and there's there's going to be no
talking you back
because when ladies in particular
are done
after holding their breath for a decade
or for
three years or for whatever when they're
done
you can't switch them back on you can't
switch them back into love mode it's
you're in resentment and that's actually
it's over that's right it's over and uh
because they they've
they reached that i've had it moment and
it's there they really have had it and
they're really gone and so don't let
that happen to you
uh it's going to happen to you if you
don't control the process now you can
control the process and you say okay i'm
gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna give him this
much time i'm gonna try these five
things to encourage him at that point
i'm gonna call this because this
relation i can't be married to a crazy
person and he's mentally ill darling
he's mentally ill we just diagnosed it
um dave
some of this feels like a
self-fulfilling prophecy to me
that if you get enough people saying
well
money's going to be of no value so let's
just blow it all and run up all of our
debts and go but
that that's the quickest way for money
to have some serious problems right is
that fair i don't know enough about
monetary policy that it just feels like
you're we're starting to see a what
rabbi lapin says he says money is not
actual it's spiritual
so when i give you a hundred dollar bill
the actual paper is not worth a hundred
dollars right it's a spiritual
transaction of trust
and so when i give you a hundred dollar
bill you accept that hundred dollar bill
for 100 in goods and services
or you get eyes get big and you say
thank you or whatever it is because you
trust that you can take that and do
something with it
and so what you're saying is and it's a
valid point that if enough people lose
that trust then the money is destroyed
or if enough people act so ridiculously
i mean if you lose if if 90 of people
lose trust in the money the exact money
is no longer currency there you go
there's no current to it right so i mean
i've got some confederate money from the
before the civil war
yeah you know what you can buy with that
nothing right there's no trust
association we have a vested interest in
saying hey instead of running from this
and acting like children
let's lock back and try to get some
let's
build civilization together good grief
yes
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt free stage
tim and sarah and gunner are with us hey
guys how are you great how are you
welcome where do you guys live
atlanta indiana okay
very cool which is near
uh we're just north of india about 30
minutes okay we'll call it indy okay
indianapolis area and you're here to do
a debt-free scream how much did you pay
off 105 000. all right how long did this
take
28 months oh ding ding and your range of
income during that time we went from
about 150 to right around 210. wow nice
jump in 28 months what kind of debt was
the 105 000 we're pretty normal dave
lawn mower motorcycle student loans
truck
you financed a lawn mower huh
yeah zero percent interest right
pay for it later
that's great
so um
what got you on this journey 28 months
ago
we blew it out for christmas in 2018 and
uh
you know
almost went bankrupt spending all of our
money there and the day after christmas
our furnace went out and we didn't have
the money to pay for it
and uh looking at our income and we we
make way too much money to not be able
to afford an emergency like this so
i had to go to the bank and get a credit
card to pay for a furnace
and uh i said never again
something's got to change yeah this is
this absolutely it's this level of
stress this level of uncertainty is not
okay
so what did you do how was your journey
like from there we'll say the first
thing we did my sister got us was the
financial peace university for christmas
so that really kicked us off it was
perfect timing i think yes okay so the
same christmas that the furnace went out
financial peace universities under the
tree a little cold in there but they
have pu's under the tree
do we read it or use it for firewood
that's right
so who had the conversation with who
well
i've been listening to dave since 2006
and i wanted to go on this journey 10
years ago but uh we didn't see eye to
eye on it and you know life kind of took
took hold of us and uh we got back on
track shortly thereafter because of the
furnace the furnace okay so you got the
box out from under the tree and both of
you went to class we did together all
right and was it was it hard to go to
class or when you went were you just so
ready that whatever it said dude we're
gonna do it no we were we were gonna
make it work yeah we were ready both of
you absolutely at the same time this
time at the same time i think the goal
setting too in the in the book when you
sit down and talk together about what
your future will be that that's really
significant for me and i think that a
lot of people don't realize that you
have to have a goal to work towards and
so doing that together was helpful yeah
dreaming about the future and
and making it very very very clear
of what that's going to be just a
crystal clear picture of it yeah yeah
this is what life's going to look like
and here's what and we're going to pay a
price to get there but it's worth it
we're going to get there absolutely yeah
very cool 28 months later 105 000 later
you're done
that's pretty cool that's very exciting
that's pretty cool mind-blowing what do
you tell people the key to getting out
of dead ass
well for me it was a ramsay solutions uh
the the ramsey plus app and every dollar
budget being able to actually see how
that app
tracked every single dollar almost every
penny that we spent was eye-opening i
think we both had some
aha moments when we realized how much we
were spending on fast food
alone so
that was it for me and then
well paying for for food with cash is
huge because you get to keep that money
in your wallet instead of you know
swiping it away with the debit card you
get to uh
it doesn't seem like it's there anymore
yeah you don't realize it it's going
away right
when it's a debit card you don't feel it
right or credit card you feel it with
cash yeah but with cash it's like ouch
we just bought something so you've got
this extraordinary handsome young man
with you here
um 2018 you blow out christmas 2019 2020
i'm assuming christmas looked a little
different the gunner home and yet i see
him still smiling and breathing tell us
about that transition yeah i think uh i
don't think he realized um really he
didn't i don't think he felt it as
probably
as we did but we're also doing financial
peace junior with him now so um he's at
an age where he can comprehend all the
things that we're listening to and doing
together and we've been practicing
debt-free screams for a long time
together
contentment was huge for us
it really didn't seem terribly
sacrificial for us to to start this
journey we spent a lot of time at our
dinner table instead of going through
the fast food and we spent
time doing things that don't take a lot
of money like going fishing
and and that doesn't cost a lot to go to
go fishing and it's really really
meaningful so yeah contentment's huge
yeah it's uh it's a i think it's a
secret weapon
it might be the most powerful of all
financial principles is to be able to be
content
uh you can avoid debt you can save you
can be generous you can do all kinds of
things when you're content yeah but
discontent man it costs like a lot of
money because you spend a lot of money
trying to find contentment and it's
expensive so have you guys had that one
month where
there's no no no payments and but the
the check still deposits oh yeah we ha
we've had a few now that's awesome tell
us look at you smiling man tell us about
it
well when you get at the end of the
month and you're doing your budget
you're like oh man we've got this much
left over i'm just going to go ahead and
slip this into this this account or add
that 15 to the
our retirement or add it to his college
fund and or maybe go eat out at a
restaurant or take a trip to nashville
it's really cool dude i wish you could
see your face man you just lit up just
thinking about it that's incredible man
good for you guys that's awesome well
done very well done you guys outside of
the two of you who was cheering you on
my sister is our biggest cheerleader
she's the one sent the fpu kid yes
actually she's listening live right now
so laura yes hey laura
well thanks laura we appreciate the
business we appreciate you appreciate
you taking care of your sister that's
awesome very very cool good and then tim
you and i met at uh entree summit so
you've taken this stuff to your business
too huh well uh
it was kind of ironic i the the explains
part of the the jump in pay i took a new
job
and uh my boss is a big uh ramsay person
and we didn't know that but i was a
ramsey person and she was a ramsay
person and she took me to entre uh back
in may and then we're going again next
uh next year in florida and
really looking forward to it but um
i try to really live and embody these
principles every day uh in my personal
life and at work too so awesome yeah
it's a great jumping pay well done good
guys excellent proud of you
well done now you're free how's it feel
it feels amazing great wait lifted off
all of our shoulders and we can uh
breathe for a little bit and then jump
right back into four
yeah just well now it's intentional not
intense right so you're going to get
there before you know it so very very
well done we've got a copy of the legacy
journey for you that's the next chapter
in your story to go on and be baby steps
millionaires that's the next thing
coming up for you and of course uh
on top of that we got a copy of the
total money makeover for you to give
away put it under somebody's tree right
before the furnace goes out that's right
for sure
that's how this stuff works got to pay
it forward now all right tim and sarah
and gunner
105 000 paid off in 28 months making 150
to 210
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream
[Applause]
that is awesome
that's so cool man i know that uh
childhood trauma sticks with you through
your whole life but also standing on
a stage oh man in front of lights with
your mom and dad who for 28 months have
been sacrificing and
and you got to come to this weird thing
a debt-free scream there used to be this
guy back when i was a kid back in
tennessee
that did these debt-free screams and
that was for daddy made his first
million that's right and you're sitting
there telling your kids that and you got
20 million yep and that's gunner yeah
and that's those moments when you can
tell your kids yeah dad used to be
grumpy and then all of a sudden
he smiled all the time and we started
going fishing and
he tried to cook that wasn't great but
mom helped and
then it's those moments like everything
changed right yeah and um that's called
changing your family career that's
incredible man
and you know what the interesting thing
is
that if you're listening to us right now
you can do it you can do it you
yeah i'm talking to you i know you're
driving on the interstate you think i'm
not talking to you i'm talking to you
right now
you can do this
i'll shut up stop your whining
you can do it
this is the ramsey shot
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host open phones at
825-5225 kevin is in denver hi kevin how
are you
doing pretty good how are you better
than i deserve what's up in your world
well i could use some help with getting
my dead snowball going and i'm having
trouble with the zero-sum budget
um i believe i'm on baby step number two
okay you got a thousand dollars
uh five
you have five thousand dollars
yes okay good well baby step one is one
thousand dollars baby step two is we
list all of our debts smallest to
largest
pay minimum payments on everything but
the little one and attack the little one
with any money we can find from any
source and that would include four
thousand dollars which is the fi the
four above the one and so we're going to
throw that at the smallest depth that's
definitely going to get you rolling
what's your very smallest debt
my smallest debt is i believe
230 dollars all right it's gone what's
the next one
what's that what's the next one
the next one is i'll have it right here
um
5
315. you go from 250 to 5 000
well see um i have a life insurance loan
i have a retirement loan
and
um
the only other
all my
utilities are basically paid i got them
on automatic pay yeah utilities are not
a debt that's a budget item
okay yeah so you and life insurance
loans going to be gone are you healthy
can you get life insurance
uh actually i have some some issues you
know i have um
obesity
um high blood pressure well actually
it's not high anymore but
i have a history of it yeah if you can
get some term insurance it'll probably
be cheaper than the whole life and then
the whole life being canceled will pay
off that loan that is not a loan you
want to repay that's a loan you want to
get rid of by getting rid of that policy
uh how much do you owe on your
retirement account
uh 3
500 300
3056 dollars and seven okay so your
second smallest debt is the retirement
account
yeah
okay
so if you had four thousand dollars in
your hand you could pay off those first
two debts correct do you have any other
debt
i do i have student loans both me and my
wife have i have 63 000 and student
loans and my wife has 119.
what do you guys make of here
a little over a hundred okay all right
now then but so we knock off these two
little first debts and we're gonna with
some of the money you had in savings
taking you down to 1 000 we're going to
get you on that zero base budget and get
you going and uh
meaning that every dollar just has an
assignment before the month begins each
and every month every dollar has an
assignment that's all it means
the every dollar app will help you do
that and i'm going to sign you up for a
year
for ramsey plus and that's going to
allow you you and your wife to go
through financial peace university
there's a really good bunch of lessons
in there on how to do that zero based
budget and the every dollar premium app
is part of it i'm gonna pay for all of
it
and give it to you free
the only thing i ask that you do is you
get your butt out of debt
get yourself straightened up and then
you go help somebody else someday but
with your generosity because you're not
broke anymore that's what i want you to
do so you hold on and kelly will get you
signed up and we'll get you moving in
the right direction and here's the deal
kevin when you and your wife sit down
every week and say what's our budget
look like
go ahead and say what is our calendar
going to look like
what are three or four things we can do
to move our bodies this week we go for a
walk together after dinner
can we go for a walk in the morning
together when we're just gonna look out
and not even say anything to one another
to have our cough whatever it
but what you're going to see is a level
of intentionality that starts with your
money that ends up with your marriage
and your relationship and your calendar
and what work looks like and what
physical fitness is going to look like
and you're going to find you said you
struggle with obesity and high blood
pressure you're going to find that that
level intentionality is going to begin
to to slowly invade all corners of your
life
and you're going to wake up in a year
two years three years you're going to be
out of debt you're going to be making a
little bit more money your marriage is
going to be different your health is
going to be different and all of this
stuff begins to work together with that
one magic word intentionality right
there's a saying that discipline begets
discipline every time but what really
happens is
that
once you take the initiative
in one area of your life whatever that
area is and you say
i can control
my behavior in this area
and then you have some success with that
it just says well i could control this
other area there
and then oh well maybe i could control
this other area the number of times
that
we see someone
get out of debt
simultaneously improve their marriage
uh
simultaneously lose weight
and it's not because they weren't eating
because they were living on beans and
rice that's not the point they were it's
just the discipline they just we had a
guy in here one time did a debt-free
screen lost 260 pounds while he was
getting out of debt i mean he was just
it was an amazing story we actually did
a a youtube special on him and put it on
youtube channel it was a beautiful story
but there's that that thing of
once i know that i can make me do
something i can do hard stuff that's
right then i know i can make me do
something else and something else and
something else there's a confidence that
builds
uh in your ability to control your
environment and there's this confidence
that's built with dave we are so we are
so beholden to these
magical things called feelings i don't
feel like working out this morning i
don't feel like eating i feel like
eating that instead of that i feel like
buying this thing and there's something
about learning
here's a budget and i want to buy this
but i'm not going to because i said it
wasn't gonna and then you start to
realize oh i need to feel these feelings
but they don't always tell me the truth
they don't have to live by them anymore
and i didn't feel like running this
morning dave you probably didn't feel
like get up and go for but we did it and
we're going to do it again tomorrow and
you can do it again tomorrow the
feelings sometimes don't matter it's
that discipline i can do it i can do
hard stuff i can do hard to live only by
feelings that's the definition of being
a child there you go
i mean adults are allowed to have
feelings but not lived by that you got
to challenge it that's right you know
adults devise a plan and follow it
children do what feels good that's right
because when you're when you're
basically a child whether you're living
in an adult body or not all you do is
what feels good but it feels good i
don't feel like it i don't feel like i'm
in love anymore i don't feel like i want
to be a dad anymore i don't feel like i
want to be a mom anymore i don't feel
like i want to work anymore i don't feel
like i and everything's about you you
selfish little brat you know and we've
all got that kid that lives inside of us
but this thing called growing up is when
you say in spite of the feelings i'm
also going to do what is wise
and what is good and what is noble and
do it anyway
i'm going to go for a walk this morning
i know it's raining but i haven't missed
a day in 517 days and i'm going for a
walk this morning i know that me and my
wife are um
not talking great i'm still going to get
up and make her coffee right and i'm
still going to say good morning how are
you i'm still going to do those things
even when i don't feel like it and
you're going to see that just bear fruit
over years and years later man that
that's what's so weird about this whole
get out of that thing it's like that
snowball okay we just paid off the first
two deaths
right just now just now did it while
he's on the air on the air and i mean he
hadn't done it yet but i told him what
to do and so you know the the that gives
you this sense of oh look at that i can
control this i can just do this i can i
can make some progress and we make a
hundred thousand dollars a year let's uh
try let's save it up for the next month
the next month and pay off the next one
right let's get on it let's get this
next thing you actually took off three
of them because he's going to go and
cancel that whole term policy he's going
to get a whole live policy um a term
life policy and um he's going to go from
there right that's a good point yeah so
we got three debts taken off one phone
call right so it's just that i don't
feel like it let me do it anyway and you
know what he didn't pay anything for
that free advice and free and i gave him
the whole thing from a couple of
handsome guys that's what you get man
where are they i don't know
they're back there with kelly and ben
yeah the next segment is on delusional
yes
i just i wish
everyone can see the power of saying i
don't feel like i'm gonna do it anyway
and you do that 30 days you do it 60
days at 90 days and literally everything
in your life changes
everything and you begin to build new
brain synapse your brain changes your
body changes your mind changes your
money change everything changes it takes
30 days 60 days 90 days but what happens
when you build confidence like that
that's called faith hope yes you know
and hope you can control that's right
you can decide to look for it yeah and
and when you don't have it it's called a
broken heart
you know the proverb says hope deferred
makes the heart sick that's right
but when desire comes
it is the tree of life i love it you can
go looking for beauty and hope you can
find it it's well and you can actually
manufacture it every single day
ah i love it man little hope factory
there we go
dr john deloney
ben and kelly in the booth good hour
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
dave here we just launched a brand new
listener survey we want to know what you
think about the show you'll be entered
to win a 100 amazon gift card no
purchase necessary take the survey
ramsey solutions dot com
survey or text survey to 33 789
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice dr john deloney ramsey
personality is my co-host today we're
talking about your life and your money
dr deloney on his show talks about all
kinds of relationship things mental
health issues of all kinds boundary
issues of all kinds and we weave those
into the ramsay show when he's along
with us and sometimes we do when he's
not and we just reference him so we're
glad he's here today open phone's at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five that's triple eight eight two five
five two two five curtis is with us
curtis is in lexington kentucky hi
curtis welcome to the ramsey show
thank you dave
what's up
well i got a question i
like you tell from many other people i
think i know what you're going to say
but i wanted to ask anyway okay i've got
20 000 worth of credit card debt
and it's charging me around 24 interest
and so i was wondering if i was thinking
about refinancing my house because i can
save two percent on my mortgage and
doing a cash out to pay off the credit
cards or do a heloc which would be
around seven or eight percent
and pay off the credit cards and pay off
the
heloc faster than i'm going to do paying
minimum payments on the credit card
okay what's your household income
about 45 to 50.
you have any money
no sir okay i got about 500
okay how old are you
65. okay
all right
well um
the problem is is that the credit card
debt is the symptom
of other things going on
and if you paid it off really really
fast the interest doesn't matter much
and it's gonna be tough to pay it off
really really fast you're working 40
hours
do you work 40 hours a week
yes sir okay what do you do
i'm i'm in transportation
okay all right are you married
yes sir and does she work
no sure how come
she's on disability oh okay
so your household income with you in
transportation and her disability
payments is a total of forty five
thousand dollars
yes sir okay all right cool
well
obviously the credit card debt is due to
overspending can we agree on that
i agree okay credit cards have been cut
up that's good good first step well done
sir
all right and so then the trick is to
get rid of them as fast as possible you
really can't borrow your way out of debt
you're just moving it around and so
you're right i'm going to tell you not
to move it over onto your mortgage
but that's going to entail that you guys
really cut your budget to the bone and
do anything you can to create some extra
income
uh and let's get those credit cards paid
off very very quickly see the interest
rate isn't the problem it's the debt
we've got to get rid of the debt
that's what's killing you and then the
interest is attached to that if you want
to refinance your mortgage in the
meantime
and lower your interest rate two percent
if you're going to keep the house that's
a wise thing to do but no i would not
recommend a cash out because i don't
want you move credit card debt where you
bought a stake you couldn't afford and
uh you now you finished it 30 years over
on the house
and that's what ends up that's what
credit card debt is i mean it was crappy
bought at target and that's financed 30
years over at the house or it's
something else you know repair on the
car and now it's financed 30 years over
on the house and so i just it just it
just sticks in my in my throat and i
just can't i can't tell you to do that i
don't think it's wise long term short
term it feels pretty good and you're
right it does get rid of a high interest
rate but i i really really really want
you to do something to get your income
up your out go down and slam that credit
card debt and say hey
sometime in the next uh 18 to 24 months
it's going to be gone that means ten
thousand bucks a year extra coming from
somewhere part-time job something
and uh attacking that and and forcing it
and getting rid of it but i'm proud of
you for cutting up those cars that's a
big first step
and um uh since i'm in the old dog club
too i can say this it's tough for us old
dogs to learn new tricks i'm proud of
you for doing that and can i tell you um
i
just for some encouragement here i've
watched my my dad's 70 and i watched him
transition a couple of different
positions over the last few years and
he's found something that he just
absolutely loves about two years ago
and so still within the same basic
um realm of his expertise but i want to
encourage curtis it may feel like i'm 65
no one's going to hire me i can't do
anything else so i'm just stuck doing
this thing that may or may not be true
depending on where you live and what you
want to do and what you're willing to
invest to learn something new and i've
watched my old man do it it's pretty
neat curtis i think you can do it like
dave said um there may be some late
nights at driving and driving on top of
driving but
just get this stuff out of your life and
you're gonna stand six inches taller
when this thing's over yeah it changes
everything for you
holler at the same time brother if we
can help sydney is in san diego hi
sydney how are you
dave how's it going
great how can we help
okay well first of all we love you
we're debt free
um and all because of you we just love
you so much um but we're wondering so
disneyland is back open
and
we are wondering if we
if it's okay for us to make monthly
payments on our disney passes just
because we're thinking
if
california shuts down again
will we be out of our money for the
passes
oh so you want to buy season passes to
disneyland
correct yes they have a month they have
a monthly plan or an annual plan
yes and it's an interest-free plan
and it is so is the if you quit paying
the monthly does the pass just stop
correct
okay well that's just like you're buying
anything else then that's more of a
subscription than it is a debt
okay so i mean you can stop by if you
bought put cable tv in your house and
you decided you didn't want any more you
stop doing it
right okay and you don't have the bill
anymore and that's what this is what's
the difference between the annual plan
and the monthly plan
um well the annual plan is six hundred
and fifty dollars up front and then the
monthly plan the monthly plan is forty
dollars a month for twelve months
so the monthly plan is cheaper by two
hundred dollars
that's something's wrong
well it's i was i'm worried 40 times 12
is 480
480 is less than 650 they're charging
you less for the monthly plan
by oh you know what i think that you i'm
sorry i think that you also have to make
a down payment when you first sign up
for the plan the monthly plan okay
that's probably equal to the difference
yeah just just do the math because you
may find out that it's five months is
going to pay for the annual plan
and i understand not wanting to have
them holding your money um if they have
if california shuts down again but yeah
do the math on it yeah make sure
you gotta have the other piece of this
what's the down payment if the down
payment's 400 now you got
880 bucks versus 650 that's not
interest-free darling
you know
it's just a different price plan where
they made you wish you'd paid interest
[Music]
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to pure talk they
use the same network as the larger
providers for much less for just thirty
dollars a month get unlimited talk text
and six gigs of data with no contract
the average family saves over seventy
dollars a month by switching to pure top
just go to puretalk.com and enter the
promo code ramsey to save 50 off your
first month pure talk simply smarter
wireless
[Music]
so
[Music]
dr john baloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today here is talking about term
life insurance all the time because term
life insurance can make all the
difference financially
for your family if you pass away your
family should not have to worry about
money at a time like that
no one should our term life calculator
makes it easy for you to find the right
policy it shows you how much coverage
you need takes less than five minutes to
get your numbers and here's what to
expect first answer a few questions to
give us a snapshot of your life
situation our free calculator will then
tell you how much coverage you need
about 10 to 12 times your annual income
and how long you need to keep the
insurance and then that's the term
and then you'll be able to compare rates
and select the best policy at xander
insurance our trusted ramsey trusted
partner they'll shop over a dozen top
insurance carriers find you the best
deal it's that easy to get your results
text term life to 33
789 we'll make all this happen for you
for free that's term life at 33789
chris is with us chris is in san antonio
texas hi chris how are you
hey dave how you doing today better than
i deserve what's up
i can echo that certainly
bob so i've been hearing a lot of your
uh
advice about life insurance policies and
that's something top of mind right now
i just turned 50 years old
so that's really a benchmark moment in
my life
and
now that i have someone in my life i
look beyonce and we'll see
oh we're listening
where'd you go chris
are you gonna come back
you wandered off
chris chris
i'm gonna put you on hold kelly will
pick up see if we can get you plugged
back in brother
all right travis is in hopkinsville
kentucky hi travis how are you
good how are you mr dave and mr john
better than we deserve sir what's up
well i'm just wondering i've got
going through a little divorce now she
woke up one day you told me she didn't
want me anymore didn't want to be with
me after a little little almost three
years
i'm sorry too got married in 2019.
well i've got a little student loan
and
a little truck loan
gym membership
and
a student loan is 185 a month truck loan
is about 375 a month
gym membership at 20 a month
and i make about 16 an hour with no
benefits a little bit of ot
and my question is should i buy the
house that i'm living that me and my
wife are living in now from my mother
at roughly 130 000
or should
me and my mother because it's her house
continue to split the payments of about
three hundred dollars a month
um
your mother doesn't live there right
correct she lives on the other side of
nashville about two and a half hours
away okay and what is the house worth
um
she said she my mother's told me she's
had offers at right now 160 just as it
sits without anybody coming inside and
looking at it but
that's just what people would offer her
that's not an actual
agent or an appraiser
how how old are you sir
i'm 27
28 december
well
sound like you've had a hard year sir
i'm sorry
yes sir um
what what i would have you to do before
you buy a home from anyone your mother
anybody else is to become debt free have
an emergency fund in place
right um so that means we need to clean
up um the gym membership is a membership
that's not a debt but the rest of it is
debt we need to clean up
and um
if you can't get ot at this place you
maybe need to look for some ot somewhere
else uh the second second
as soon as i get off the phone with you
i'm headed to my side hustle to mow
yards okay good good well you're not
afraid of hard work that's for sure no
sir and um so the the on the career side
of things the next question you start
asking yourself is i'm 27
um
and i make you know 30 35 000 a year so
what um
what am i going to be doing when i'm 37
that pays double that
and what steps have i got to take to get
there those are ken coleman type
questions if you've ever listened to him
and so to develop a long-term career
path that gets you
up and beyond where you are there is no
shame in where you are at all you're not
afraid of hard work you work hard for
the money that you got i'm proud of you
for doing all that uh but i don't want
you doing the exact same thing making
the exact same money ten years from now
do you
no [ __ ] okay so what is your plan what
are you going to be when you grow up so
to speak well i actually um just quit my
job about a month ago
and now i'm doing i follow ken coleman
and i did jump out on a limb and started
my career path i'm the assistant golf
course superintendent
at a local golf course here and looking
to move up to the head superintendent i
like it okay you're way ahead of me then
all right i'll step back then and let
you and ken run that path you're doing a
good job with it well done thank you all
right yeah let's hold off on buying the
house till you're debt free and have an
emergency fund in place and that is also
going to give you the side benefit of
giving your hearts your broken heart
some time to heal yeah
travis is something we do when somebody
pulls the the carpet out from under us
is we start trying to grab for stability
and it feels like buying mom's house is
gonna give you a foundation
and right it's it's it's not it's gonna
be another albatross around your neck
right now because you can't afford it
okay because i've lived here for 25
years and this is where i grew up as a
kid no i gotcha there's your heart your
heart is looking for a place that's
going to receive it back right
yes sir what i want you to do is stop
looking at truck payments stop looking
at other payment find out how much you
owe and get out of debt and let that be
where you begin to get stability get
stability in
taking steps after step after step
towards a whole guy don't try to look
into your past and try to re recreate
something you've had and your mom may
say well then forget you i'm gonna sell
the house if that's what she chooses to
do that's what she chooses to do go rent
a one bedroom apartment while you climb
out of this mess exactly but you can get
there man exactly so here's okay so ken
is giving you a path to run on and john
just gave you some really important
words there
um the old joke is
that broke people tell you how much the
payments are rich people tell you how
much debt they got right
you know how much down how much a month
that's the broke people talk
uh how much
is what rich people ask
and so not how much debt they've got but
how much that's what they say not not
how much down how much a month so quit
thinking of your debt in terms of
payments start thinking of it as i have
this much car debt i have this much
student loan debt and i got to get rid
of it you may have to sell your truck
you may i mean you do what you got to do
brother get out of debt and find that to
find the stability walking forward yeah
and that the beautiful thing about that
is it gives you something to focus on
while your heart is healing that's right
and uh and you don't have to buy a house
right now uh so that house will be there
you're gonna get all this done probably
a year and a half two years then you'll
buy the house from your mom's probably
what's going to happen
or you may decide you don't want to live
there that's okay too by the way
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five scott is in las
vegas hey scott welcome to the ramsey
show
how you doing uh i just want to thank
you uh first of all for your plan uh and
uh your teachings on goals because
uh between being debt-free as of today
i will be uh i've lost 54 pounds and
we're talking about that in the last
days yeah yeah look at you
where'd it go
but my question is uh
right at the moment i am uninsurable
and
through my current job i have
life insurance approximately 210 000
good and i want to know uh like what
uh if i'm looking to change jobs to get
more income
how much of a salary increase
would it be worth
to make the change
so why are you uninsurable
i had a heart attack four years ago and
i've had a couple uh different uh you
know throwing they've
done some stints two other times since
then okay and uh i'm obese uh not as
much as you were yeah you're four down
brother so you're on your way to you're
on your way to solving this long term
that's right short term you need the
coverages um
there's not enough income
to just say oh the family will be okay
if i die
uh i gave up you know two three times my
salary so
[Music]
i'd want to make a lot more if i changed
in the short term in the short term no
it's not going to take care of them if
you die but i'd want to make a lot more
because you start to look at some
policies
that are going to be rated but you can
get them and that's in your near term
future
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying sixty thousand dollars about
two years after that i got a remote job
that pays me a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars all thanks to what i
learned at bethel tech you could be next
get started today at betheltech.net
and get 1 000 to 2500
off of your tuition again it's
betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt-free stage ethan
and taylor are with us hey guys how are
you hey dave better than we deserve how
are you better than we deserve welcome
where do you guys live uh we live close
to wilmington delaware oh yeah okay cool
welcome to nashville how much data have
you paid off forty six thousand forty
six thousand dollars how long did that
take about seven months wow whoa and
your range of income during that time
started around 73 ended around 76. cool
what do y'all do for a living
i'm an engineer and i'm a standalone
stay-at-home dad and also he did some
door dashing too okay cool what kind of
debt was the 46 000 it was two cars some
student loans and some phones
wow
okay so tell us about your journey what
put you on to this and what made you
decide to do it and what'd you do
so the start of the journey was
definitely my maternity leave where i
decided to pick up the book that had
been sitting on my shelf for a couple
years at that point
oh the old dust collecting routine yes
it finally called out to me when i had
some free time um and ironically my
mom's actually the one that got it for
me and as i started digging into it her
and my dad were
hesitant about some of the advice but
obviously we went all in yeah um in
september we sold my car and that's whoa
it got real serious yes
that's when things got real serious
right
what did you sell what kind of car chevy
cruze okay and what did it sell for
like
12 or something we owed like 15. okay
and the other car is what uh honda hrv
okay all right fun
fun so when you got when you started
selling cars the parents are like i'm
sorry i gave you this book and now
you've joined a cult and i'm worried
about you and
yeah it was the stopping the 401k
contributions that made my dad worry ah
okay well it's a temporary thing dad
come on
he hears you right now so i'm glad you
can tell him
[Laughter]
i don't blame him i understand the nerd
part of it but uh we have found that
when people focus on something is when
they went at it and that's what you guys
have done you you went all in yep and so
after we sold the car then we started
just playing a show all the time at our
house that's how our one and a half year
old is a huge fan of you because she
just sees you on tv all the time oh my
gosh while i'm on her and especially the
debt free screams too she was first even
just learning how to clap she's always
loved to clap for those so she'll be
exciting to see what she thinks today
for sure
that's great that's
so uh what do you tell people the secret
to getting out of debt is
um let's say first secret is a zero
based budget um even people who don't
want to hear my dave ramsey spiel i tell
them about zero-based budgeting like
here minimum everyone would benefit from
zero-based budgeting yeah congress
congress
for sure um and then just being all-in
gazelle intense don't let anyone
convince you not to be
all in who had the first conversation
with who that sat down and looked across
the table and said i think we should do
this and you're an engineer so did you
spreadsheet him no no just kind of the
broad concepts to get him intrigued by
it i think you got to start a little bit
and work your way in with all the
details the very mystical baby steps
yeah were you you were all in yeah
absolutely
just like that just
cool i mean you did it in seven months
that's impressive yeah yeah you like you
sprinted through the big thing march so
we paid off everything in april and
march we had a ton of windfalls it was
like i was saying hey you guys are meant
to get out of this quickly and so we had
like 12k and win falls just in march so
that helped speed things up a lot and
sold a 12 000 car that helped as well
yes so that's 24 of the 46. yeah all
right that makes a lot of difference and
then you knock the rest of it in the
head wow
very very good cool so the zero-based
budget is the secret and uh what else do
you tell people
just to have a clear goal just be
focused and very very clear it's not
nothing gets in the way
yeah that's
it sounds so simple
yeah until you start actually doing it
and you know then all kinds of stuff
there are legions of spouses right now
looking at you man um thinking
i wish it was that easy
you get to sit across the table and say
that's what we're doing and you'd go
okay we'll sell the car tomorrow okay
come in have a great day that's awesome
man
[Laughter]
the world needs more ethan's out there
this is true very fun
very fun so outside the two of you who
are your biggest cheerleaders probably
our parents
other than the questions yeah
okay towards the end they were convinced
as the numbers starting you know to go
in our direction like oh this might
actually be good yeah yeah look at that
they're free yeah how's it feel to be
free great incredible was it worth
selling the car to get it oh yeah
it's worth every bit of it absolutely
all the windfalls throwing it all at it
everything you get so much more control
you can see your budget and as you pay
off the debt more and more is in your
control and you can say this is where i
want that to go not to that payment not
to that other bank for them to build
their skyscrapers
what was it like in may or june when uh
you got your paycheck deposited and then
you didn't have any bills
it was crazy it's pretty wild huh yeah
just start to see the numbers go up in
your emergency funds that first time you
know going from 1k to 2k is like well it
doubled yeah yeah that's a lot of fun
what was the hardest part of this for
y'all
staying focused i guess when not many
people are ramsey-minded yeah
that's true that makes sense okay cool
and you brought the one and a half year
old with you nate what's her name emily
emily is one and a half years old and
she's been practicing clapping to her
dead free screen as long as she's been
clapping indeed that's awesome what a
way to learn how to clap i like it
that's good stuff we got a copy of the
legacy journey for you that's for sure
your next uh
chapter in your story you are changing
little emily's legacy for sure and we
got a copy of the total money makeover
for you to give away so it can collect
uh dust on somebody else's shelf until
until it calls out to them so that's how
it's supposed to work it's the world's
largest uh coaster
little girl she is precious goodness
cute cute cute
fun stuff
all right hey kiddo
what's up
all right here we go ethan
taylor and emily wilmington delaware 46
000 paid off in seven months making 73
to 76 000 a year count it down let's
hear a debt-free scream three two one
[Applause]
i love it
oh that's fun
that is exactly that how this is
supposed to work well done well done
patrick is in tampa hi patrick welcome
to the ramsey show
oh hi thank you for taking my call dave
sure what's up
all right um
now i've been working on your baby steps
for a while now i'm in trying to
eliminate all my debts out
now
unfortunately there is a collection
that's on my record
that's been on there for uh since 2018
that i really
do not want to pay because it's really
shouldn't be my responsibility to pay
that why
well because
well here's the thing
that collection came from an apartment
complex that
i moved out of in 2017
that they gave me that
me and my brother moved out of so when
we moved out
we they gave us the okay to go uh live
in this new apartment complex
and then when the leafs ran up on it
which was around september and october
september i'm not sure when but it's
around that time
me and my brother was already in a
different apartment complex
and and then while my mother was already
because i was living with my mother at
the time
but we was already gone at the time and
then
when we come to when we decided to go
find other place of uh to live in from
the new carpet conference we got it
that's when we discovered the uh
collection on our record why did they
put a collection on you why did you own
money
well according to the uh lawyer because
i was like i said i was living with my
mother at the time and we all signed the
lease
that's just me my two brothers and my
other three siblings
they said that according to them that
since that we
our names are on the lease still
and my mother didn't move out at that
time
and when the lease was up
it was a whole barrel hold over to it so
therefore we owe the money on actually
they're right and you're wrong you own
the money
and so what i would do if i were used
i'd get on the phone with them and
create a a dollar amount hopefully at a
discount that will settle with them and
i'd pay them yeah and get it out of your
life it's not going away
they got you
you you lose
not only do you lose on a moral basis
because what they just said actually
occurred she's living in the apartment
she's a holdover tenant they charge your
rent and your name is on the lease you
guys were irresponsible on how you
handled the business transaction and it
came back to bite you in the butt
so you're gonna need to go clean it up
hopefully you can settle it for a few
dollars and be done with it and not only
get off your record but get it out of
your life and out of the back of your
mind
and it'll feel good to clean up and do
the right thing because that's really
what you need to do here
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture today first corinthians 16
13 and 14 be on your guards stand firm
in the faith be courageous be strong do
everything in love henry ford said one
who fears failure limits his activities
failure is only the opportunity to more
intelligently
begin again
oh i like that failure is only the
opportunity to more intelligently begin
again good stuff brandon is in miami hi
brandon welcome to the ramsay show
oh my god like
thank you for that
the prayer right now um
cause
thank you guys for being men of faith
too that you guys are teaching people
thank you and honestly changing lives
and it's something that i look up to and
i spend hours
hours and hours and hours watching these
videos
and
i'm
seeking
i'm not sure because i started a
business um
a couple years ago and i was in debt and
i basically started from zero like
handing out flyers to
people and what i do is i clean and
ceramic coat boats
so
i have an opportunity to make
good money
but it's just
i don't feel like i'm that deeply rooted
like i'm not passionate about
it so i just wake up and i go do the job
and then it kind of feels sometimes like
i'm dragging and i'm bringing home
pretty decent money but
it just doesn't feel purposeful
what kind of money are you making
um it depends on the job like sometimes
i mean what do you make in a year
i haven't i really haven't done the
numbers that that good like that well
you did your taxes opinion
yeah so what'd you pay taxes on
i think it was around like 40 but
the thing was that i also
i i slack off a lot it's not that i'm
working every single day too i work once
or twice a week a week
okay so so brandon this isn't a passion
problem it's not a job problem this is a
branding problem
what you're doing is you're watching a
lot of videos trying to find that one
spark that's going to get you up and
going
and one of the themes of all these
videos you're watching is you just got
to get going
yeah it's been my experience now hold on
people get passionate about things
they're good at and you get good at
stuff that you practice over and over
and over again
and you're not gonna
yeah you're not gonna get passionate
about something it didn't have to be
this job
but you're not gonna get passionate so
i'm working i'm good at it yeah but you
only do it two days a week man it's
nothing to do with the job today
it's a choice
why aren't you getting up every day and
going and doing it five days a week
um
i don't know i just here's the thing i
drive for it if if if i gave you any job
i have a feeling that in about two
months you'd start slacking off is that
fair
no okay good
i'm glad you pushed back so what do you
want to do man
see that's what i was gonna say so i'm
kind of
i'm doing this bit i'm doing this
business but then on the side i've
noticed
and it's just it rubs off on me that
people are spending ridiculous amounts
of money on just
basic stuff and no one has any money
saved up and this is an actual problem
that i see going on so then i just you
guys preach
and i feel like i'm so attracted to it
that's why i spent hours on it because
i resonate with this and
this information i've helped my friends
get out of debt and i've helped them
like change their lives but it always
feels like then when i go work for a
paycheck
then
i'm not into it
so i was thinking that maybe i continue
doing what i have to do now for for a
salary
and then on the side
um help people with their finances
you can start that way i mean you could
go through the
master coach training program that we
have and learn how to do financial
coaching and maybe just help some people
at your church with at first and and see
if that lights you up
but in the meantime it's going to be
really good discipline for you to force
yourself to work five days a week
or six
yeah do you struggle with depression man
um
yeah i guess mental mental health but
how long have you struggled with that
god do all that
um
i mean i'm never diagnosed
i know but i know it's been my whole
life okay your whole life how old are
you
oh 24.
i want you to go talk to somebody
that's gonna be your first courageous
step
and go tell them that it's hard to get
out of bed sometimes
that sometimes it's hard to find
motivation to do work and you find
yourself trapped in these internet
cycles
where you're watching and watching and
you love being connected to people in
those magic moments
because this is bigger than this this is
bigger than i just don't have passion
for cleaning boats you may not and
that's okay man
but this is this is bigger than that
like dave said
the discipline of i'm going to get up
every day and go work six days a week
is
and that's not the issue isn't either
because i'm a hard worker i i can go
like this morning for an example i woke
up by five and i got the boat done
around 12.
and yeah
you're a hard worker but you seldom work
exactly
exactly so by definition that's not a
hard worker you should have three boats
today or not [ __ ] if you could have
three boats today and three boats every
day this week and next week and the week
after yeah i i think i think what's
happening is is that um
i think john's telling you something
that's very very important
um
you're exhibiting the symptoms of
someone who is depressed
you've got no energy to get up and do
basic things in life
and that is one of the symptoms of
someone who's struggling with depression
and i don't i don't think it's a thing
that's going to put you in the hospital
i don't think it's going to ruin your
life but i think you're going to
whatever you set your hand to you're
going to struggle with because of this
until you deal with this and i i don't
know what it was that
that happened to you that that's caused
this but this lack of energy
uh a focus of the ability to play
through other than in short bursts
is an indicator you really do need to
sit down and talk to a good counselor
and there's no shame in that by the way
the shame would be if you don't do it
right
and and so this is these are two guys
we're not um you know we're we're not uh
uh we're not psychiatrists we're not
prescribing drugs to you we don't know
any of that stuff we're just saying our
observation of life is
that um
if you were my son i would put my arm
around you and i would walk you to a
coach to a counselor that can walk you
through this
and say all right let's do it it might
be it might be a fairly short period of
time that you learn some things about
yourself and all of a sudden you start
feeling your energy level come up that's
exactly right and when you've been
living under a
cloud heavy blanket for so long yeah it
just feels like
well just i'll go look at the next thing
and that thing will light me up and that
will light me up and then you get little
glimpses of joy little glimpse of that
fire coming to light inside of you when
you help somebody get out of debt and
that might be your future man
but right now
you're that future of going to help
people get out of debt is going to turn
into the same thing that you're dealing
with the boats and the same thing you've
dealt with with every job you've had
since you're a little kid
and that is that
well let's just go back to the computer
and maybe later maybe later maybe later
so man you are worth going to talk to
somebody and have that light on all the
time yeah brandon uh you're a good guy
absolutely
love yourself enough to go work on this
plan really do
um
again if you were my son my son's a
couple years older than you i just put
my arm around you and i would hold you
so tight you couldn't get loose and we
would walk into a counselor's office and
you sit your butt down and i would walk
out and let them talk to you and make
you do it because that's that's how
strongly i feel about it okay
and uh and that would be a dad loving
his son that's all it would be and so
that's what i'm doing that's what we're
doing right now so just feel my arm come
around your shoulder i'm not letting go
of you you are walking in there bud
now you're doing this okay and that's
gonna change it's gonna help everything
everybody goes through
sometimes
that they that they have dealt with some
level of trauma and it knocks the breath
out of you
and says
different people takes them longer to
get their breath than others and that's
all we're talking about that's exactly
right and then sometimes right when
you're about to get your breath again
something else pulls you back and right
it's just it's the season and that's why
you need people whether they're
professional or
their
friends and or and or that's right yeah
you need connection you need both of
them but um yeah you gotta have people
to walk with you and there's gonna be
seasons i don't wanna get up and come
shoot another show
and you get up and you go again right do
it don't do it anyway dude anyway if you
can't do that that's that blanket on you
go talk to somebody yeah that by
definition then that's
good for you brandon thanks for calling
man absolutely
good job john good job ben and kelly in
the booth i am dave ramsey your host
we'll be back with you before you know
it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
prince of peace christ jesus
[Music]
dave here we just launched a brand new
listener survey we want to know what you
think about the show you'll be entered
to win a 100 amazon gift card no
purchase necessary take the survey at
ramseysolutions.com
survey or text survey to 33 789
[Music]
you